les vacances de février en un parfum de
printemps avant l'heure comme à
collioure dans les pyrénées-orientales
les charmes de la station balnéaire
enchante les touristes et les habitués
et toutes générations confondues néo
lambert temps parce qu'elles pensent à
collioure dans les pyrénées-orientales
l'hiver est chaleureux cet après midi au
soleil
il faisait près de 20 degrés les
stations de ski ne sont pourtant pas
loin mais même en février on trouve ici
des touristes qui ne viennent pas par
hasard pour le soleil pour la mer la mer
alors on est bien c'est calme il fait
beau il ya moins de monde que l'était
j'imagine puis on en profite
nous venons d'angleterre ayant ce moment
comme presque partout en france
il fait froid et gris mais ici sur la
méditerranée il y a un beau soleil c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que nous sommes dix
ans cette saison
collioure joyau de la côte vermeille
accueille surtout des retraités des
grands-parents venus avec leurs
petits-enfants et qui préfèrent le calme
de ce port de pêche aux pistes enneigées
c'est plus facile avec les enfants aussi
c'est moins de contraintes en contrainte
on n'est pas trop skieurs en plus à
petit une clientèle qui recherche plutôt
doux des curiosités culturelles et les
visites et ils n'ont pas forcé y
viennent pas pour se baigner pour les
plages idem pour les sites en fait ici
la saison démarre à peine la moitié
seulement des restaurants et des hôtels
sont ouverts demain c'est l'ouverture de
l'hôtel il ya une semaine donc c'est le
début de saison mais c'est pas vraiment
s'est pas encore vraiment lancer un
chien commence doucement
oui ça commence tout doucement je pense
plus à partir d'avril mais là ça va être
vraiment le grand lancement le grand
début de saison
collioure capitelles du fauvisme est
aussi un lieu de villégiature apprécié
des peintres et pour eux la meilleure
saison c'est l'hiver en été c'est je
fais plus banal ça fait peu la poudre
wacom effet les couleurs va pas bien
blotti entre mer et montagne couviour
est un peu une exception car à cette
époque de l'année la plupart des autres
stations balnéaires de la région
hibernate encore